Deadly fungal outbreak linked
to a Michigan paper mill.
Officials now say one person has died
and there are 97 confirmed or probable
cases of what is called
blaster psychosis.
All of the cases
have been in Michigan's
Delta and Menominee counties.
The infection is caused
by the fungus blast or misses
It lives in mostly moist soil,
soil and decomposing wood and leaves.
And you can get it
simply by breathing
in the microscopic fungal spores.
Joining us now is Brian Peterson.
He's a vice president of operations
at the paper mill there.
I think that he is with us,
although he may not be.
Can you hear us
You're there, okay?
Yes, I can hear you just fine. Yes.
Thank you so much for joining us.
We really appreciate it.
Can you tell me we know that
one person has died
Have you been in contact at all with
the contractors family?
We have.
I have not been in
contact with the contractors family.
We got news of that
from the county last week.
And we are just now getting involved
in the investigation.
When you worked in the mill in the last
this year,
what he was doing in the mill
as far as work goes, that kind of stuff.
So we're cooperating
with the investigation at this point.
Do you know how people are getting sick?
There are now some 100
confirmed cases somewhere around
97 to 100 confirmed cases.
Do you know how they're
they're getting it
Unfortunately, we don't.
Since we were first told of this
from County Health in March 3rd,
we've put a full court press
on trying to understand it.
And as you said,
blessed with psychosis is in wet soil.
It's our understanding
from talking to CDC,
there's no real other studies
even close to this. And that's true.
So we've invited a variety of experts.
We're working towards the root cause.
We invited niacin
to do what's called a health
hazard analysis,
which they
got the first phase of that done.
And we're working through
those recommendations.
The next
round of cleaning,
we've decided to idle the metal to do.
It's just too disruptive
and there's too much risk
to try to do the cleaning
with people in the mail.
So we are this morning
or almost done in the mail
and will commence with that cleaning.
Okay.
So you've idled the mill, you're
clean, you're
trying to clean
to make sure
the spores aren't
in the air for people to get sick.
Can you give me some sense
of how
the other 97 or so people are doing
and what some of their symptoms might be
Have you learned that
in your investigation?
Well, I'm
not an expert in blasting psychosis,
although I'm getting there fairly quick.
So I would encourage you
to talk to the CDC
about all the symptoms,
because they can be
quite broad but we've had
people with very mild symptoms
taking, taking medication and working
just fine
up until including you
talked about the fatality.
So it's a wide range.
It has slowed down here
in the last couple of weeks
as far as number of new cases go.
But we are taking this
with the utmost seriousness to go ahead
and get
get what we know out of these complex
mostly around
like ventilation
systems, things like that,
which are
very hard to clean and bigger buildings
in areas that were people were affected.
I got to ask you,
this is the first time
I've heard about this
and I know it exists in the world, but
has this ever happened?
Have you ever heard about this happening?
At the plant, at the mill before
No, I have
never heard personally of any outbreak
like this.
You know, it is
it is native to this part of the world.
I can't say
there's never been one,
but we're sure
there's never been an outbreak like this
in this mill or any mill that
that we've been able to find.
And is there any sense
that you believe that the spores were
you know, in
sort of wet paper or sort of
some of the
some of the items in the mill?
Or is this coming from the outside in
talking to the CDC?
You know, because it's it's
where it is originates from
and it's airborne
you know,
we believe
it had to come from outside somehow
and then got into the air.
I mean,
if I look at all the affected cases
or the affected people and employees,
and then you start to map out
where they work,
you're really trying
to understand
where, where
or what is in common
with all of these employees
or contractors.
You know, where have they been in common?
So we can try to get the root cause.
And that's really pushed us towards,
you know,
the areas that we're going to clean.
This is people's work.
This is how people make a living
at the mill.
Can you give us some sense
of when the mill will be back
fully functioning
and safe enough for people to return
You know,
right now
we're planning up to three weeks
to get the cleaning done
and we think we can get that done.
It's a very dynamic
and evolving situation, as you know,
and so we have people
as we're just getting the mill
finished up idle this morning,
we have experts that we worked with.
They asked to get in the mill
for the cleaning
and we'll learn a lot as we go here
in the next next few days.
Brian Peterson,
thank you so much for coming on
explaining this.
It is a really interesting
and sad situation that's happened there
at the mill with your employees.
I appreciate your time.